[Music]
until the premiere of the Kelly Clarkson
show Wow
so you think Kelly Clarkson's a little
excited while her talk show debuts
September 9th on NBC but you know Kelly
still has a lot of work to do on The
Voice and the competition is about to
get tougher this Monday because Adam
Levine is bringing the heat with Charlie
puth Charlie you ready to do the voice
yes my advisor the season is Charlie
puth guys no pressure
the great thing about this is you're
making it your own I'm excited to hear
what y'all did with it we just love
talking about music and really our kind
of cut from the same cloth as far as our
influences and the things that we love
this is definitely us friend ship I have
had with someone who's been on the show
Charlie is Adams real life voice best
buddy and we sat in on one of their
sessions I think we should stop because
the song is so please mega talented and
he's my friend
yeah he's super cool and I love him I
would say all the same things too I hope
so
no I genuinely need that the voice
battle rounds begin Monday and Charlie
and Adam have some ælis competition
Kelly's got Kelsea Ballerini John Legend
Khalid and Blake's enlisted the help of
Brooks & Dunn these guys have
accomplished everything musically that
we dream of they're iconic but win or
lose it's all good for Adam whose
advisor is also his bestie there's a
sweatshirt actually that I have in there
as I wore yesterday it's great
sweatshirt what is this very expensive
actually if you want it back in every
half your stuff is at my house so and
half your stuff is at my house
sleepovers you know Charlie's not new to
the voice he was a mentor for Alicia
Keys back in 2016
[Music]